>> What do you Sterling what do
you think about public understanding of genetics, in
particular? Do you think it's would you give them an A plus? Would you give em?
>> I wouldn't give them an A plus. But I'd give them a potential for having an
A plus. I think that the impact that personal
genomics and the rate at which discoveries are happening I think
that this is going to force the hand of education
in the public arena. I think that people both
are going to be interested, and are going to want to
learn more about the nitty gritty of genetics. And
I think that right now there's just a lot
of wonder and curiosity. And there's some people that
have really good information, and there's some people that
have really bad information, just about like anything. and genetics
you know, as you know, can be both a simple, some simple concepts to some very
complex one. And the information that one gets from their own personal genetic
background has both of those things. And it has the potential to be
confusing and to be a minefield of misinformation,.But
I, I hold a positive I think there's
a positive potential for people learning and understanding.
>> What's, what's always so fascinating to
me, is when we meet new parents, average
sized parents, that have had a dwarf child.
And it always comes to, they tell the
story of when they were given the
diagnosis. And 90% of them, have horrifically bad
stories to tell, about how they were told
their child was going to be a dwarf. And
I always want to go back and hear the other side of that story. You know, was it
just a shock to them and, and they read
negativity into it? Or was that negatividly, negativity actually delivered?
>> Mm-hm.
>> I just want to know in general, do you
have any hopes or fears for the future of genetic research?
>> Well, a cousin of mine, the daughter of my
uncle who was BRCA2, found out she was BRCA2, and she's
in the process of seeing physicians. And one physician said to her,
based on her age, and my age, and my uncles age, that
there's research going on. And they're probably within the next few years, they
will find a moderator mutation.
Because, why is it that there's a spectrum of people who would get breast
cancer? And so, th, we don't know this yet. But my, that's my hope as well, that
the research will continue, and that they will
find out that some people, why do some
people get breast cancer, who have BRCA2 and
some people don't? Is it environment or is
it drinking too much alcohol, or not enough alcohol?
>>
[LAUGH]
>> You know, what is it?
>> Hopefully that second one.
>> Yeah, yeah. So, I think I definitely believe
in research, and rewarding the companies that make these contributions.
>> So you, so you think the journey,
you hope the journey will continue into research.
>> Right, yes.
>> And funding the research.
>> Right.
>> What else?
>> I think of it from the perspective of my grandchildren that
will come in about 10 or 15 years, and all of this
testing will be pu, back in the forefront in our family. I guess
I'm, I'm, there's a sense of relief knowing that my boys
as future dads, will have the information available to them.
And they will have the freedom of choice, to do with that what they choose.
>> I hope it continues, and I hope
it doesn't get out of hand, whatever that means.
>> I think, for me, my best hope would
be that the information progresses, to the point where that
it helps people who are looking at cures and
treatments. That it helps them do their job, and that
it helps the general public make informed personal
decisions. My fear is kind of, it's lighthearted if you've
seen the movie Gattaca? That's basically the, one
of the fears of it going out of hand.
Where there is, you know, people are forced
to make choices or where socioeconomic status can determine,
like, people can take more advantage of this. I
mean, it's kind of a lighthearted ja, I fear.
But, you know? It's, it's legitimate to fear that. And, that kind
of embodies the fear of, you know, people make, having their ability to
make the choice taken away from them, due to socioeconomic status, or outside
pressures, I think. Because, my hope
would be that it remains personal decisions.
>>
my hope is that, you know, it will help individuals make medical decisions
in a more informed way, both in themselves, and with clinicians. and that
like, for instance, pharmacologically, like, the
pharmacological principles. Once we know the genetics
of how we may respond to certain drugs, you know, we'll be able
to fine tune which drugs would help us more, which
one's will more likely produce side effects. that's just an example.
>> I think one thing that all of you touched on, but
we never brought out into the open so directly, is the idea of
genetic determinism. And really in your own way, you each have brought to this
course, by representing a trait or a particular background how gray
genetic determinism really is, and that human beings
are not just their genes. Right? We're human beings.
We're not just one trait. We're many traits. we're
many people together. And that I hope for the
future, that this genetic information is, we're able to
use this together, to realize all of the many
wonderful things that it means to be human and
to make us unique, individually and as a species.
and that my only fear is that we grow
out of our adolescence of, you know, misunderstanding each
other, and, and I hope that we can understand
how we make decisions, and consensus about these ideas.
And I, I think very truly that it's in
great part to people's willingness like your own, to
participate in projects like this, and other educational opportunities
that that's going to be possible. So thank you for
[CROSSTALK]
for being here.
>> Thank you.